[Musique]
dans le débat sur France 24 consacré à
la vague djihadiste au Sahel alors que
le Burkina Faso a encore connu à
massacre d'une cinquantaine de civils il
y a une dizaine de jours et que deux
casques bleus égyptiens ont été tués et
un autre blessé au Mali la zone des
trois frontières entre le Niger le
Burkina Faso et le Mali et le théâtre
d'action sanglante de mouvement dialyse
lié à Al-Qaïda et au groupe état
islamique au Mali des groupes armés et
les forces maliennes ont lancé une
offensive contre les djihadistes pour
reprendre une ville frontalière du Niger
la gente qui gouverne c'est d'ailleurs
donné jusqu'à mars 2024 avant de rendre
le pouvoir aussi vivre alors le Sahel
devient-il un sanctuaire pour les
djihadistes quels sont les risques d'une
contagion dans le reste de l'Afrique
quel est l'impact du retrait de la force
barkhane du Mali et des décisions de la
jante au pouvoir comment s'organise la
stratégie anti-dialiste dans la région
djihadiste menace sur le Sahel on en
débat avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés wassimastre
sa France 24 bonsoir Voici ma
spécialiste des mouvements djihadistes
auteur de état islamique le fait
accompli et c'est chez plomb bienvenue
dans le débat en face de vous Vincent
Huger bonsoir journaliste indépendant
spécialiste de l'Afrique auteur de
tyrans d'Afrique et ça c'est chez Perrin
bienvenue Vincent également avec nous
niagalé Bagayoko bonsoir président de
l'africaine security secteur network
autrice de le multilatéralisme
sécuritaire africain à l'épreuve de la
crise saélienne et c'est aux éditions
Québec Montréal nous avons avec nous
également Louis Magloire que maillot en
direct de Lomé Louis magouar bonsoir
journaliste et président du club de
l'information africaine voici on va
commencer avec vous au Mali on apprend
qu'aujourd'hui des groupes armés et des
forces maliennes ont lancé une offensive
donc entre des djihadistes pour
reprendre une ville frontalière du Niger
qu'en est-il est-ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que le groupe état islamique
contrôle la frontière entre le Mali et
le Niger en fait c'est un offensive qui
a été lancé par le MSA qui un mouvement
touareg pas aussi les gattias et par une
faction par unité particulière de la
même manière c'est le groupement
tactique 8 qui est à majorité et touareg
et pourquoi je précise cela parce que
c'est une initiative propre aux
populations locales pour essayer de
contrer les tailles islamique qui a fait
monter en puissance de pied avril et qui
est responsable de plusieurs massacres
ils ont essayé d'associer d'autres
factions du Nord comme le CMA ou le HCA
qui n'ont pas voulu participer à cette
offensive on a une carte où on prévoit
l'évolution de cette de cette offensive
et les localités qui sont contrôlées
aujourd'hui par l'État islamique ou
évacués par les civils donc de fait
c'est l'état islamique qui règnent tout
ce qu'on voit en noir donc l'opération
qui a démarré le 4 elle visait un drame
qui était utilisé comme comme dortoir et
comme infirmerie pour l'État islamique
après les opérations des mycémies inecar
est un malade ça a démarré en avril donc
vous voyez bien toutes les localités et
le fief de l'État Islam dans cette zone
c'est inaraban donc il y a eu une un
départ de convoi depuis Gao vers un
drame sauf que l'État islamique s'est
retiré de la ville donc le convoi
constitué du MSA gatia et le GTA 8 a élu
domicile dans l'anciennes des femmes sur
place sauf que c'était un piège on va
dire de l'État islamique il aura envoyé
le 5 au matin 10 motos pour simuler une
attaque le 5 juin le 5 juin là ils les
ont suivis jusqu'à 40 km à chajalat où
ils sont tombés dans un guet-apens 40
véhicules le chef d'état-majoratif a été
blessé au torse et à la main c'était une
débandade on va dire et les forces qui
se sont impliquées on a des photos des
convois là c'est le début de l'opération
qu'on a dit et de j'étais à 8 sauf que
c'est finalement il faut le dire c'était
un échec donc le pari était très risqué
de départ mais les gars auraient pu être
important après il y a des calculs
politiques qui sont entrés en jeu Bamako
a aidé il faut le dire
munitions en quelques armements pas de
véhicule mais pour le moment là on parle
Bamako n'a rien communiqué par rapport à
ça parce qu'encore une fois c'est un
échec maman
islamique est là on a rien changé
plus que 15 véhicules dont me dit-on le
véhicule du chef d'état-major des
gattias il a pas avec dans la ville donc
ce qui était voulu comme opération pour
contrer on va dire l'état islamique qui
qui depuis trois mois évolue dans cette
zone sans sans frein va se retourner en
train de se retourner parce que
évidemment l'état islamique va pas se
priver de dire que c'est une victoire
pour lui et ce qui est à noter aussi
donc
tactiquement ils ont été plus faibles on
va dire que l'État islamique donc ils
ont sous-estimé leur ennemi qui a prouvé
qu'il a une capacité si on parle
évidemment de manœuvre qui est très
importante donc de commandement qui est
très important c'est par exemple que
Moussa Moumini pour le nommer que lui
est un chef important mil pas de l'État
islamique s'est déplacé sur son il y a
une semaine on sait que les plans
d'offensive vers Gao devait être couplé
d'un plan d'offensive vers une delimane
ça n'a pas été le cas et que ces plans
même certains estiment que l'État
islamique les avait et donc il s'est
préparé à cette offensive qui était mal
ficelé et dernière chose par rapport à
cette offensive donc soutenu par Bamako
mais pas jusqu'au bout il y a pas un
hélico qui ont été envoyés il y a pas de
de de force qui a été rajouté à cette
force mais aussi j'ai pu apprendre par
des sources au Niger que plus de
réunions pendant le ramadan ou cette
offensive devait se préparer en
coalition avec d'autres factions comme
hcia le CMA et même peut-être barkhane
et que ça a été déconseillé il leur ont
dit c'est trop tôt vous êtes mal
préparés sauf que les on va dire les les
l'aspect politique de la chose a pris le
dessus il y a eu un pari un pari risqué
qui finalement a échoué et alors on
parle l'État islamique contrôle une
partie de la frontière entre le Niger et
le Mali où il est en train de lire un
SAN dans une zone riche en eau où il
peut se cacher des drones et des frappes
et une zone il faut le rappeler
contester entre les populations locales
depuis un moment donc il a réussi à se
greffer sur des dynamiques antérieures à
son existence donc ethnique de terre et
d'eau et sur lesquels il est en train de
capitaliser on a vu ça ailleurs et c'est
comme ça qu'il réussisse à construire
quelque chose on va dire de durable et
pour le moment ils y arrivent malgré les
pertes de d'un nombre de leur chef et
malgré l'effort déployé par différents
pays et par Berkane pour les contrées
Bagayoko donc on voit cette frontière
donc entre le Mali et le Niger
effectivement la progression du groupe
état islamique il s'installe
pratiquement c'est ce que dit Wassim il
se développe grosso modo dans l'ensemble
on parle de cette zone des trois
frontières on va revoir la carte entre
justement ces trois pays comment
expliquer en fait que ça a été si rapide
parce que finalement on parle de trois
mois là pour le Groupe Islamique même si
comme moi aussi me vient de le dire il y
avait effectivement un terreau déjà
favorable alors je pense qu'il est
effectivement très important de se
pencher sur ce terreau et sur les
dynamiques communautaires qui
sous-tendent aussi ces affrontements il
y a un empas douter une rivalité qui
s'est fait jour de nouveau notamment
entre la communauté touareg daoustak et
la communauté peut notamment tollée B
dont un grand nombre de membres font
partie du groupe état islamique même si
l'on se rencontre si on écoute les
communications téléphoniques etc qu'il y
a aussi aujourd'hui ce qui n'était pas
le cas avant des locuteurs Haoussa zarma
etc donc on ne peut pas considérer qu'il
y a une un affrontement entre touareg et
peul mais cette dynamique qui est fondée
notamment sur la question du contrôle
des espaces de l'accès aux ressources au
pâturage et aux surfaces agricoles
exploit est un conflit extrêmement
ancien donc à mon avis on ne peut pas
totalement parler de
conquête mais plus exactement d'une
greffe et de l'adhésion à l'état
islamique de certains ressortissants qui
étaient d'ores et déjà en conflit
précédemment autour de ces logiques
Vincent je comment procède-t-il on parle
on a vu véhicule piégé distribution de
tracts en langue locale il multiplie un
certain nombre de techniques ces groupes
djihadistes le groupe état islamique en
l'occurrence mais pas seulement il y a
aussi le groupe Al-Qaïda pour étendre
leur zone d'influence l'un des facteurs
de l'essor continu de l'emprise
notamment de l'EGS mais c'était vrai
également pour la matrice Al-Qaïda
notamment dans le centre du Mali c'est
d'exploiter à son profit effectivement
des ressentiments qui sont ancrés voici
Mania galet il faisait allusion dans de
vieux contentieux alors le contentieux
traditionnel entre les agriculteurs les
pasteurs mais si on prend l'exemple du
Niger par exemple le président Mohamed
Bazoum lui-même admet et d'ailleurs ça a
été le cas lorsqu'il a entendu la main
aux jeunes nigériens égarés il sait très
bien et d'ailleurs il l'a admis dans un
entretien récent que ces jeunes en
question ce sont souvent par exemple des
fils de pasteurs peul considérablement
ta pauvrie par un triple phénomène une
sécheresse récurrente qui évidemment est
une calamité pour le bétail des RADIAS
qui sont opérés par différents groupes
armés qu'ils soient ou pas liés à la
mouvance islamiste et puis également
l'expansion des terres agricoles et donc
cette compétition permanente entre ce
que l'on plante et les aires de package
pour le bétail et ça il y a une sorte de
génie politique il faut l'admettre dans
la capacité en évidemment couronnant
tout ça d'une justification sacrée de
nature religieuse de tirer profit de
tous ces vieux conflits malletins tous
ces sortes de brasiers qui qui rejoint
en permanence et qui peuvent évidemment
à la faveur de cette aventure politique
immunitaire resur donc au fond quand
Bazoom dit que il le faisait dans un une
interview accordée à le président Niger
3 et à l'Obs voilà quelques jours quand
il dit notre frontière avec le Mali et
sous la coupe de l'État islamique c'est
à peu près imparable et un dernier point
si on renvoie une le film et qu'on
essaie d'élargir un peu la focale
souvenons-nous qu'il n'y a pas si
longtemps notamment après le fameux
sommet de peau nous a expliqué que la
priorisation du combat contre l'État
islamique allez l'affaiblir ayant encore
quelques semaines voire quelques mois
des stratèges militaires et politiques
français nous expliquer que oui l'état
islamique avait été affaibli à
l'évidence non il ne l'a pas été sauf
que ce qu'il faut rappeler que après
évidemment il y a un effort important
après haut mais ce qui a surtout
affaibli l'état islamique c'est la
guerre avec Al-Qaïda donc c'est la
guerre intestine entre les deux qui a
finalement affaibli qui a contenu l'état
islamique plus que les efforts
militaires découvrent juste pour
rebondir à ce qui a été dit qu'est-ce
qui représente à côté justement du
groupe état islamique en terme de nombre
schématiser pour cette frontière par
exemple vous parliez un danger on va
dire sécurité et militaire pour
schématiser et Al-Qaïda constitue en
danger sécurité et politique parce
qu'ils sont ancrés dans les relations
locales je veux juste rajouter quelque
chose par rapport au grief ancien et
antérieur au groupe djihadiste
aujourd'hui il y a une nouvelle
un nouveau nouvelle chose qui s'ajoute à
l'équation c'est la guerre entre
Al-Qaïda et islamique donc ça dogmatise
des deux côtés avant ce qui était un
groupe oui mais ça dogmatise plus ça
dogmatise plus les recrues ça veut dire
avant on voyait des recrues juste
participer à une attaque pour le butin
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus possible
moi-même j'ai écouté des audio de
Mohamed Koufa qui est numéro 2 du génie
d'Al-Qaïda en train d'expliquer à des
jeunes recrues les sources du conflit
entre Al-Qaïda l'état islamique avant
même que la guerre entre un éclate au
sel et ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
on a des combattants aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus dogmatiques qu'avant et
c'est une équation c'est quelque chose à
prendre en considération donc l'état is
retrouve ses sources chez le Mujao le
Mujao on est en 2012 ça fait à 10 ans
qu'ils sont là donc ce qui démarre avec
une insurrection et des brigands peut se
transformer en haut de choses et juste
dernière chose par rapport à ça les
brigands qui ont rejoint l'État
islamique en 2018 au Niger aujourd'hui
ils ont plus on va dire le les faveurs
de l'État islamique central que aboli
sahraoui qui a été tué par les Français
parce que l'État islamique central
considérait que vous le voyez il était
très toujours très proche d'Al-Qaïda
alors que les nouveaux chefs ont des
choses à prouver donc il leur donne leur
province donc tuer des chefs pour
revenir aux opérations de Berkane c'est
une loterie et surtout d'où la
difficulté de considérer qu'il y a des
groupes armées terroristes en général
alors qu'ils s'affrontent comme vient de
le dire Wassim les uns contre les autres
Louis Magloire que maillot a vous êtes
justement au Togo quels sont les risques
de contagion avec d'autres pays
d'Afrique on se souvient de ces attaques
par exemple dans ce parc naturel
transfrontalier c'était au mois de
février il me semble-t-il un parc du
Bénin est-ce qu'effectivement dans les
pays frontaliers et on sent cette menace
djihadiste
on ne se contente pas de la sentir on la
vie par moments aussi au Togo seulement
on en est aujourd'hui à trois attaques
qui ont eu lieu il y a eu une première
qui s'est déroulée à la frontière avec
le Burkina Faso il y en a une deuxième
qui a eu un peu plus loin dans les
terres mais toujours dans la zone
frontalière avec le même Burkina Faso et
récemment il y a eu une attaque dans le
grand marché de Lomé ou un ressorti
santiagiens à poignarder mortellement un
gendarme avant de se séduire saisir de
son arme puis un policier s'est occupé
de lui a essayé de le neutraliser
malheureusement il a été poignardé ces
jours ne sont pas en danger mais le fait
que s'il avait réussi en arrachant
l'arme de ce gendarme à tirer sur la
foule il aurait fait un carnage énorme
et peut-être que cela aurait été mis sur
le compte de l'islamisme violent et du
djihadisme pour ne pas parler du
terrorisme donc aujourd'hui je pense que
l'enjeu est d'arriver à faire comprendre
au pays de la côte sur le elle arrive de
l'océan Atlantique que la menace
terroriste qui plane et qui s'était
enracinés au niveau du Sahel pourrait
très facilement s'étendre dans les pays
de la côte ça a commencé en Côte
d'Ivoire on l'a vu également au Bénin il
n'y a également eu le Togo donc il y a
de fortes chances que cette menace qui
semblait très lointaine deviennent une
réalité quotidienne et dramatique pour
les pays de la côte également voici une
sur les modalités justement de
fonctionnement on va revenir sur la
minusma qui a été donc attaquée qui a eu
deux morts un blessés c'est c'est un
convoi qui a été attaqué comment il
procède en fait ça dépend ça dépend des
des modèles des cibles hein par exemple
là ils ont attaqué un fourgon de la
minusma akidal et il y a un
militaire jordanien qui est mort là
c'était une attaque avec des ARPG et à
la mitrailleuse parfois c'est des IED
donc des engins explosifs improvisés sur
les bords de route etc donc ça dépend de
la cible et parfois plus rarement on va
dire ils envoient des voitures piégées
avec des kamikazes dedans là c'est quand
la cible est importante par exemple un
convoi de barkhane ou par exemple
dernièrement c'était Al-Qaïda contre un
convoi de la minusma du contingent
allemand donc ça dépend de la cible et
des effectifs qu'ils ont par exemple on
sait aujourd'hui que Al-Qaïda n'a aucun
mal à fabriquer de l'iode ce n'est pas
le cas de
frangin explosif improvisé voilà ce qui
est pas le cas pour l'État islamique ils
ont une défaillance de l'État islamique
en production d'engins Express improvisé
ce qui pourrait changer s'ils ont
l'apport par exemple du Nigéria donc ce
qu'on surveille aujourd'hui à la
française
en avril il y a eu des combattants qui
sont venus du Nigéria non armée qui se
sont armés sur place et participer au
combat donc il y a un apport de
combattant mais s'il y a un apport de
compétences humaines donc fabrication
d'explosifs donc fabrication de requêtes
artisanales ou ne serait-ce au niveau
tactique l'usage de drone civils etc ça
pourrait changer la donne ou usage par
exemple domicile anti-char comme on a vu
en Libye donc les modopes sont
classiques il y a rien de nouveau
l'armement est rudimentaire
humaines c'est la compétence humaine qui
fait la différence
avec de plus la vulnérabilité assez
impressionnante de convoi qui peuvent
s'étirer sur des kilomètres je pense à
des convois de ravitaillement
alimentaire ou de carburant ça a été le
cas depuis le 22 mai le 22 mai c'est
hier matin vous avez eu 6 convois de
cette nature plus ou moins longs qui ont
été attaqués parce que précisément
lorsque vous ne contrôlez pas les
arrières et bien vous êtes évidemment
très exposé à ce type d'attaque avec la
fluidité opérationnelle que voici
elle est bloquée la route nationale 16
elle est bloquée depuis le 25 mai à
différents endroits dans la série da qui
va on va dire entre Garou et qui
traverse qui longe le le Niger le Niger
c'est la ligne de vie en quelque sorte
et alors ce qui est intéressant c'est de
constater que cette fameuse minusma donc
la mission des Nations Unies au Mali
dont le mandat actuel expire dans
quelques jours et d'ailleurs il va être
question de son renouvellement
et bien cette minusma est aujourd'hui
considéré à juste titre comme la mission
onusienne la plus dangereuse du monde
vous avez 164 casque bleu qui ont été
tués depuis je ne parle pas des blessés
qui ont été tués depuis 2013
c'est-à-dire l'année du lancement de la
Dick mission oui par des opérations de
nature terroriste ces affrontements en
tout cas avec les djihadistes au Mali
coïncides vous le savez avec le retrait
militaire en cours de la France de ces
alliés européens la jante qui gouverne
s'est donné jusqu'à mars 2024 avant de
rendre le pouvoir aussi vivre cette
annonce intervient ou sur le lendemain
d'un sommet de la CEDEAO qui a imposé au
Mali de Sévère mesure de rétorsion pour
faire pression justement sur la jarte on
fait le point en image avec Florent
Renaud
elle dirige le pays depuis son coup
d'État de l'été 2020 sous pression de
ses partenaires ouest africains la jante
militaire malienne s'est engagée à
rendre le pouvoir aussi vivre dans moins
de deux ans date butoir de cette
transition le mois de mars 2024
le décret a été signé par le colonel
assimigoïta l'homme fort de Bamako deux
jours seulement après une nouvelle
réunion de la CEDEAO elle qui avait déjà
imposé le 9 janvier dernier de ces vers
mesure de rétorsion commerciale et
financière comme la fermeture de
l'espace aérien malien à ses voisins ou
encore la suspension des échanges de
biens non essentiels cette communauté
économique des États de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest voulait un délai maximum de 16
mois les militaires maliens ont
finalement opté pour 5 mois de plus bien
loin de leur rêve initiaux de conserver
le pouvoir pendant cinq ans un nouveau
sommet de la CEDEAO doit se tenir le 3
juillet prochain il pourrait permettre
une levée graduelle des sanctions si les
différentes étapes de la transition sont
franchis avec succès
on voit que le maïs s'isole quel impact
ça peut avoir justement de la lutte
contre les djihadistes
alors justement on voit très bien que
l'un des arguments qui avait été mis en
avant par les militaires qui ont pris le
pouvoir au Mali mais également par ceux
qui ont pris le pouvoir au Burkina Faso
et celui de leur capacité à rétablir la
sécurité à l'inverse des civils pointés
comme ayant été en échec sur ce front là
or on remarque que les résultats tardent
à se manifester même s'il faut
distinguer entre différentes zones la
situation Dans le centre du Mali n'est
pas celle de la région des Trois
Frontières dont nous parlons tout à
l'heure et on voit que les offensives
qui ont été notamment menées
dans le centre du Mali par les forces
maliennes en lien avec leur partenaire
russe ce sont révélés extrêmement
sanglantes en revanche on a constaté un
véritable attentisme du côté de cette
frontière entre le Mali et le Niger d'où
l'événement que constitue que
aujourd'hui l'engagement d'une unité
très particulière bien sûr puisqu'elle
est plus ou moins une émanation du
gattia aujourd'hui mais le défaut de
résultat véritablement probant
aujourd'hui en dépit d'un certain nombre
de déclarations qui peuvent être faites
par les autorités militaires maliennes
interrogent et laisse penser que tout
comme les partenaires de la communauté
internationale 7 ennemi est
particulièrement difficile à réduire
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire niagaler Bagayoko est-ce que c'est
particulièrement compliqué et est-ce que
les États se donnent les moyens
finalement comment s'organise-t-il dans
cette lutte contre le djihadisme on voit
que le Mali s'isole est-ce que c'est le
seul État à s'isoler est-ce que les
autres au contraire les autres États du
Sahel essayent encore d'avoir une action
ensemble
je crois que la lecture militaire et la
lecture surtout qui consiste à dire que
il y a pas de volonté n'est pas
suffisant parce que pour pas que nous
oublions que nous sommes dans des pays
où qui sont en situation soit d'État
failli soit des terres en situation de
transition parce qu'ils ont connu des
situations très difficiles sur le plan
de la stabilité politique et
sociologique et que aujourd'hui ils
n'ont pas forcément tous les moyens pour
affronter les défis qu'ils doivent
relever je le dis parce que non
seulement il y a eu le cadre qui a été
créé par la France à travers le Q5 Sahel
mais il y a eu également une autre
initiative celle de de
Dakin qui a été monté pour aider les
différents services à échanger des
informations dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et puis pour pas oublier non
plus que la minute main n'est pas
constitué que de force exogène au
continent africain il y a beaucoup de
pays africains qui contribuent aux
forces de la MINUS mais que cela n'est
pas suffisant et ce n'est pas suffisant
parce que pour l'instant l'on reste sur
l'idéologie islamiste et sur la
dimension militaire du conflit or il y a
une dimension économique et de
développement qui est de mon point de
vue encore beaucoup trop sous-estimé et
qui pourrait avoir son son qui pourrait
peser son pesant dehors dans la
révolution de conflit à partir du moment
où à la suite des victoires militaires
on essaierait de développer davantage
les zones en question d'investir
davantage de la part de l'État ces zones
là pour permettre aux citoyens d'avoir
non seulement les services de base
auquel ils ont besoin mais notamment la
sécurité et puis la protection dont il
ne bénéficie toujours pas donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui au regard des droits de
pirates spéciaux qui ont été accordés
par rapport à des prises cette fois
sanitaires pour permettre au pays de se
renflouer il faut bien voir comment sur
le plan social et militaire on pourrait
faire en sorte que l'armée ne soit pas
là pour donner des coups de force mais
également pour apporter un plus dans le
développement et avoir une coopération
entre États qui ne se limite pas au
cadre du G5 dont le Mali tant de voler
même si la volonté du chat de réintégrer
le Mali et surtout la médiation du Togo
pour permettre au Mali de revenir au
sein de la CEDEAO voici
une sale depuis que le Mali se retirait
n'est plus que l'ombre d'elle-même ou
est-ce que c'est encore une force
importante une force militaire
importante il faut voir comment ça va
s'articuler derrière déjà le G5 Sahel
donc il y a eu une c'était moteur de
quelque chose mais qui finalement n'a
pas vraiment changé la donne sur le
terrain parce que ce qui marche encore
c'est vraiment quand il y a des quand il
y a une pression pour qu'il y ait des on
va dire des coopérations plutôt
bilatérales c'est ça qui qui marche donc
quand des États se mettent d'accord par
exemple Tchad Nigéria Cameroun faire une
opération ça marche sinon ça ne marche
pas donc évidemment le départ du Mali va
lancer quasiment lancé quelque chose de
nouveau mais en tout cas on est dans
quelque chose de nouveau aujourd'hui par
exemple si on parle du Burkina le
Burkina est demandeur mais jusqu'à un
certain point donc un certain point les
militaires au Burkina ils disent ben il
faut pas que la France soit trop visible
dans son engagement alors que quand il y
a eu une attaque à côté de Djibo ils
étaient bien bien on va dire avisé et
d'appeler les Français à l'aide les
Français ont juste un passage d'avions
de chasse qui a finalement mené à
l'arrêt de cette offensive mais tout ça
c'est un on va dire c'est du calibrage
parce que même au Niger si le Niger est
demandeur aussi de la présence française
il faut voir comment elle va être
calibrée si on regarde comment le
président Bazoom a réglé par exemple le
le l'incident de terrain donc en
indemnisant les familles en
collaboration avec la France
moitié-moitié donc d'une façon on va
dire à l'ancienne pour pour schématiser
ça démontre aussi qu'il y a une volonté
de d'essayer de trouver des règlements
ou la France peut jouer un rôle mais qui
reste en adéquation on va dire avec avec
les demandes ou les préceptes du terrain
ça ne pas refaire les mêmes erreurs qui
ont été faites au Mali cette
omniprésence en masse en volume et
essayer de dicter on va dire la marche
des choses Vincent donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a un tournant même en ce qui
concerne la présence militaire française
on sait que barken est en train de se
redéployer qu'elles ont quitté le Mali
il y a surtout une gradation il faut pas
voir le Sahel central comme une entité
militaropolitique homogène vous avez en
quelque sorte malgré quelques
tiraillements mineurs le bon élève de la
classe c'est le Niger de Mohamed Bazoum
vous allez le cancre impardonnable c'est
le Mali et vous avez le des efforts mais
peu mieux faire c'est-à-dire le Burkina
Faso avec lequel les relations sont
quand même moins exécrables qu'avec
assimigoïta si vous voulez c'est vrai
que la popularité de ces régimes
militaires qui est incontestable elle
est fondée moins sur la fascination pour
été prouvé ces sociétés sahéliennes pour
le jeune officier intègre ou supposé
telle entrée que sur l'exaspération
intense suscité par l'impuissance de
pouvoir civils bon donc la légitimité de
ces pouvoirs militaires elle repose sur
deux promesses nettoyer les
écureuilogias de la corruption on verra
mais évidemment avant tout se montrer
plus performant sur le front sécuritaire
ce qui est d'ailleurs intéressant au
passage
a déjà une germe depuis un certain temps
on est quelques avoir d'idée dès le
début que si les régimes militaires
imaginés qu'en substituant les miliciens
Wagner à la force barkhane il serait
plus efficace il se ferait le doigt dans
l'oeil jusqu'au coude et au-delà donc ce
qui se passe d'ailleurs et c'est assez
intéressant c'est qu'à ma connaissance
et je parle sous votre contrôle il me
semble que on n'a pas repéré d'éléments
russes Wagner dans les épisodes dans TV
question alors que ils avaient été
extrêmement actifs dans le carnage de
Moura où il y a eu la mort d'au moins
300 civils dans une opération punitive
ou à l'évidence c'était une opération
coordonnée conjointe entre les FAMAS et
Wagner donc si vous voulez un jour
viendra et je termine là-dessus un jour
bien ce que vous voulez dire donc du
coup je veux dire c'est très simple j'y
viens un jour viendra il faudra que ses
pouvoirs de fait qu'il soit perçu ou pas
comme légitime par les populations
concernées rendent des comptes est-ce
que oui ou non ils ont rempli la
promesse qui était la leur de faire
mieux que cette combinaison réputé
funeste entre l'ancienne puissance
coloniale et des gouvernants civils
impuissants ou défaillants et
aujourd'hui du côté du Burkina Faso
justement on voit de plus en plus de
voix s'élevées pour dénoncer la
passivité en tout cas la très grande
difficulté de l'autorités actuelles et
de l'armée à faire face à la dégradation
croissante de la situation notamment du
Pokémon
dépopulation du Burkina
au sein de l'opinion publique on voit de
plus en plus de voix parmi la société
civile ou des parties d'opposition
s'élever pour dénoncer le fait que les
nouvelles autorités militaires ne sont
pas du tout plus efficaces que les
autorités civiles qui les ont précédés
sans coopération militaire on se prive
de la couverture aérienne c'est-à-dire à
la fois du renseignement et de la
possibilité de monter à très bref
échéance un raid punitif ou préventif et
ça Wagner n'est pas capable de proposer
ça donc pour le Mali la présence
française globalement est-ce qu'elle est
quand même importante en dehors du Mali
maintenant qu'elle se redépose donc vous
dites vous disiez plutôt au Niger mais
pas seulement quel va être c'est le rôle
après on soupçonne que le Niger va être
un point important de cette présence
mais il y a toujours une présence au
Tchad il y a une présence moins public
on va dire au Burkina mais les forces
spéciales françaises sont présentes
là-bas depuis un moment et de plus en
plus depuis retrait du Mali il y a une
collaboration mais encore une fois comme
je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
collaboration c'est un truc d'orfèvre
quoi parce que même les pouvoirs actuels
voient actuels au Burkina il a pas envie
aussi d'appeler la France à l'aide tous
les jours et donc on arrive dans une
situation est-ce que il faut appeler les
forces françaises ou pas est-ce que les
forces françaises quand elles agissent
c'est encore des Nations avec les forces
burkinabè on se rappelle l'épisode où
par exemple il faut ici que le
djihadistes ne sont pas ils bougent en
face ils réfléchissent par exemple il y
a eu une
ID par exemple contre des forces
spéciales françaises ou un des
militaires a eu des blessures graves
irréversibles c'était au Burkina c'était
un point un aérodrome où les militaires
français mettaient du matériel pour
pouvoir opérer alors les djihadistes
l'ont repéré ils l'ont détruit ils
savaient que les Français allaient
revenir ils ont mis un IOD et les
Français ont payé le prix cher premier
dès contre les forces françaises au
Burkina c'était encore quelques mois
donc en face aussi c'est pas statique ça
bouge et aussi ça s'adapte et les
frontières ne sont que théoriques
finalement donc ce dont on parle la
collaboration inter-étatique et les
frontières etc les djihadistes font
fille de tout ça et ça fait partie de la
force et justement vous pouvez réagir
peut-être que Magloire comme Ayou
justement dans le Togo et dans les pays
qui sont côtés comment est-ce qu'on
perçoit la France justement le rôle de
la France dans cette lutte contre les
djihadistes
je crois qu'il ne faut pas sous-estimer
le contentieux néocolonial qui entoure
cette intervention de la France parce
que je suis le premier à dire que ni la
Russie ni la Chine et encore moins
aucune autre puissance ne vient pas
jouer le rôle des Africains à leur place
cependant la France a eu au moins 9 ans
pour trouver de quoi il était capable
les résultats ils sont là c'est
qu'aujourd'hui même si on a coupé la
plupart des têtes des mouvements
islamistes il n'en demeure pas moins que
ces mouvements n'ont pas perdu ni en
agilité ni en capacité de nuisance donc
l'idée ici n'est pas de t'installer dans
un brin de fer entre la France et les
pays concernés mais d'arriver à réussir
quelque chose une alchimie qui fera que
la France sera une valeur ajoutée pas
une valeur contestée mais une valeur
ajoutée dans la lutte contre le théorie
le G5 ça est constitué de 5 pays et l'un
de ces pays dont on parle peu s'appelle
la Mauritanie il y a pas d'intervention
française là-bas il y a pas de base
militaire français pourtant je n'ai pas
l'impression que c'est le pays qui se
qui s'en sort le moins bien parmi les 5
pays du g75 en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme donc je crois qu'au-delà
de tout ce qu'on peut avoir et
impatience je la comprends en premier
quand on est exaspéré par toutes les
attaques que l'on subit au quotidien on
est tenté de
constater et de dire que les forces
militaires ne jouent aucun rôle mais les
militaires ont été beaucoup moins
présents au pouvoir que les civils
toutes les opérations aujourd'hui que ce
soit de corruption de népotisme et tout
le reste qui ont fait que le terrorisme
s'installe non pas été le fait des
militaires donc quand on arrive avec le
bilan qui n'est pas glorieux et qu'on
doit résoudre les problèmes obtenir des
résultats rapidement je suis pas certain
que le pack de fête de vouloir désigner
un bouc émissaire soit suffisant et je
pense qu'à côté de ça il y a une
organisation régionale comme la CEDEAO
qui de mon point de vue ne devrait pas
uniquement être dans le rôle perfecter
suspend par exemple les pays où il y a
des coups d'État mais qui arrive à
trouver des solutions je ne dis pas ça
juste pour faire plaisir au régime
militaire mais quand vous prenez un pays
comme
Ukraine aujourd'hui et un régime qui a
été contesté par moment mais avec
l'invasion russe on a un but de côté
tous les grilles est-ce qu'on pouvait
avoir contre son administration et ses
militent pour lutter contre l'inversion
l'invasion militaire russe donc pas
qu'au niveau du Sahel cela devrait être
à peu près idem arrivé à créer une
solidarité d'abord régionale entre
l'Algérie le pays refrain du Sahel et
puis dans la mesure du possible associée
toutes les autres forces qui pourraient
apporter une valeur ajoutée pour obtenir
des résultats mais ce qu'il en est dans
le rôle de celui qui lui est bon ou les
mauvais points ou de celui qui veut être
à nous dans une dans un rôle de fausse
collant je crois qu'on aura de grosses
difficultés à résoudre le problème des
questions d'autant plus que la question
de base militaire et du franc CFA reste
des plaies béantes dans les relations
entre la France et les pays africains
est-ce que cette guerre contre la
djihadiste peut-être est-ce qu'elle peut
être gagnée tout simplement mais
les états est-ce qu'il faut
effectivement qu'ils se rapproche plus
qui est que la CEDEAO et un rôle peut
être aussi militaire qui est plus de
régionalisme est-ce que les États sont
suffisamment puissants pour agir seul
est-ce qu'effectivement la guerre contre
les djihadistes peut être il me semble
que justement le problème et que
l'approche c'est exclusivement ou trop
de mère trop importante concentré sur
cette approche militaire il n'y aura pas
de sortie de crise sans une approche
politique de la question et l'on voit
aussi et à mon avis il est absolument
essentiel de le mentionner que les trois
pays du sel central se sont tous engagés
dans des processus de dialogue si ce
n'est de négociation à différents degrés
avec certains groupes djihadistes le cas
donc il faut
intéressant puisqu'il joue sur les
différents volets sur le volet militaire
sur le volet du dialogue sur le volet de
l'amnistie sur le volet de la
diversification des partenariats à mon
avis il n'y aura pas de solution sans
que l'on considère ces différents
piliers de la gestion de crise en
sortant d'une approche trop
exclusivement sécuritaire il faut
négocier donc avec certains djihadistes
absolument ouais ça veut dire la
négociation fait partie du panel de des
solutions parce que quand on dit
négociation déjà il faut imaginer aussi
que par exemple le genyme akmi a annoncé
à plusieurs reprises qu'il acceptait de
négocier avec
IBK puis avec l'agence que l'agence a
accepté etc ils ont même fait des
communiquer pour dire que la guerre avec
la France et au Sahel et la France n'est
pas concernée
ça dépend ce qu'on met dans le panier
qu'est-ce qui est à négocier est-ce que
c'est pareil les filles et les garçons à
l'école ça négociable est-ce que faire
appliquer la charia au niveau civil et
pas au niveau pénal c'est acceptable
est-ce que amener la des réformes on va
dire rigoristes est acceptable ou pas on
parlait de la Mauritanie tout à l'heure
la Mauritanie a tapé très fort mais elle
a aussi négocié pas un attentat en
Mauritanie depuis 2011 le Niger
aujourd'hui le président bazoon a initié
de négociations avec les tailles
islamique ça veut dire mais
islamique donc il faut voir ce qu'on met
dans le dans le panier c'est ça aussi
qui est important la dialectique
entre le tout militaire et le tout
politique n'est pas un jeu à somme nulle
part quand même 70% de militaires à 30%
de politique ou l'inverse l'ennui avec
la négociation c'est glissademia on a
une préfiguration de ce que pourrait
être la société rêvée pour les têtes
politiques les cerveaux du djihadisme
aujourd'hui c'est aussi ce qui se passe
en négociation locale dans le centre du
Mali dans le Pays Dogon etc oui
effectivement en contrepartie d'une
quiétude d'ailleurs relative et
incertaine on impose des normes sociales
de comportement des normes
vestimentaires la teneur même des
prêches du vendredi etc le problème
problème là-dedans quand par exemple
mohamed
Bazoum dit il faut en gros séparer le
bon grain de livret les jeunes égarés
qui ont été menus plus par une sorte de
ressentiment social et voir la misère
tout simplement et ceux qui adhèrent
doctrinement a un projet c'est que ce
projet il est totalitaire c'est-à-dire
que les djihadistes n'ont pas vocation à
simplement se contenter un jour de
cabinet ministériel jado compatible qui
prendrait un peu de la norme rigoriste
et qui accepterait d'autre part une
ouverture c'est bien la difficulté
par exemple juste pour schématiser parce
que ça veut dire un état islamique
possible par exemple au Niger un détail
il faut dissocier islamique état
islamique la négocie pas les tailles
islamique fait des trêves ponctuels pour
se renforcer et taper encore plus fort
derrière j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler
avec beaucoup beaucoup de gens c'est pas
quelque chose qui est propre qui qui est
apte on va dire à la négociation alors
où on parle ça veut dire ils discute des
choses mais on peut pas arriver à des
accords avec du côté pourquoi parce
qu'ils veulent automatiquement ils
peuvent pas aller plus loin
alors que du côté d'Al-Qaïda qui est à
l'expérience 30 ans de Jihad etc ils ont
cette on va dire
capacité à faire de la politique c'est
comme ça qu'ils se sont implantés dans
le normalis et dans le centre en faisant
de la politique par exemple la justice
locale il voulait pas s'en mêler sauf
qu'à la demande des gens ils se sont
mêlés de ça il y a eu vraiment des
directives très strictes pour ne pas
refaire les erreurs de 2012 ça les rend
pas plus plus on va dire plus
démocratique évidemment pas mais il faut
voir aujourd'hui dans la dynamique
actuelle où on a l'état islamique
Al-Qaïda il y a des populations dans le
centre et dans le Nord qui se disent il
y a pas l'état malien les Français
partent on choisit le moins pire c'est
Al-Qaïda voilà c'est à dire il faut
essayer aussi d'imaginer ce que les gens
ont au jour le jour les gens ils ont
besoin de sécurité et de vivre les
idéaux plus plus noble on va dire de
liberté et de droits de l'homme etc ça
vient après quand on assure pas son pain
quotidien et sa sécurité les gens ont
d'autres impératifs à la frontière déjà
on vient de voir la carte il y a des
populations entières qui n'étaient pas
concernées par le diable des armates des
pollations Peuls etc qui sont obligés de
faire un choix entre qui et qui en
l'absence des états entre l'État
islamique et Al-Qaïda qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait donc là aussi les états c'est pas
ne parviennent pas toute façon à limiter
cette menace il n'y a guerrier Bagayoko
ils ne peuvent pas eux puisque en fait
vous dites faillite des états ils
étaient trop faibles ils ne peuvent pas
vaincre
mais la question est celle effectivement
du schéma global quel est le projet de
société qui est proposé par ses états
Wassim parle du fait que certaines
populations adhèrent au projet
djihadistes parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une défiance envers celui qui est
proposé par les États post-coloniaux
considérés comme ayant failli en termes
de démocratisation en termes d'éducation
en termes de décentralisation en termes
d'urbanisation et c'est ce modèle là qui
est en question aujourd'hui y compris
dans la rhétorique une fois politique de
certains acteurs djihadistes affiliés à
Al-Qaïda donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
les scénarios possibles en fait Vincent
Vincent je là ça veut dire que on peut
effectivement avoir un certain nombre
d'États dans le sel qui bascule qui
deviennent des États islamiques alors je
n'ai pas de boule de cristal mais ce que
l'on peut envisager puisque vous parlez
de de scénarie ça n'est pas à mon sens
une sorte de vaste califace aérien qui
serait une sorte de
islamique très urgence d'un rêve ancien
ou peut-être des royaumes et des empires
des siècles précédents c'est pas ça
c'est plutôt à mon avis le fait que les
élites politiques locales vont devoir
concéder vont devoir négocier sur le
plan encore une fois sociétale peut-être
économique la question du taux d'intérêt
dont on sait qu'elle est récurrente sur
le plan de l'éducation sur le plan du
statut de la femme sur le plan de la
façon d'enseigner le Coran et de prêcher
le vendredi et ces voilà ces États n'ont
en fait sans doute acheter leur survie
en échange d'une série de concessions
dans la vie quotidienne mais là je parle
effectivement plus de la nébuleuse
Al-Qaïda parce que je crois
effectivement comme moi il me disait que
les tailles islamique lui est très
binaire on est dans la coercition on
s'impose par l'écrasement de toute
adversité c'est pas du tout le cas des
stratèges et des cerveaux de l'année
que nous constituent pas une une menace
politique on va dire parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les tas de pensante quelqu'unda a en
face si je menace militaire alors mec
qui est moins grave que j'ai pas comment
schématiser ça une menace militaire il y
a une réponse militaire mais une menace
politique d'un groupe imbriqué dans la
population depuis 30 ans avec un circuit
économique et une certaine acceptation
de son existence dans la société au nord
et dans le centre et ils veulent descend
plus dans le sud sauf qu'ils ont pas le
les compétences et les hommes assez
compétents pour descendre plus au sud
même au Burkina ils ont pas les hommes
compétents mais le jour ils auront ces
gens-là là ça serait une autre affaire
ce que n'a pas pour leur l'État
islamique mais ça ne veut pas dire que
des des que des têtes pensantes ne
peuvent pas venir d'ailleurs du Nigéria
ou d'ailleurs pour pour on va dire
dynamiser tout cela encore une fois je
répète c'est quelque chose de mouvant
c'est quelque chose qui s'adapte ils
sont pas figés les états locaux et même
les États occidentaux les américains
français compris sont beaucoup plus
figés dans leur approche que le
djihadistes oui enfin ça veut dire pour
les états
islamistes non violents non armés qui
jouent un rôle très important on a cité
le cas de la Mauritanie mais le cas du
courant de l'imam dico au Mali notamment
et à ne pas négliger même si les
autorités actuelles ont réussi à le
marginaliser c'est une voix qui portera
à l'évidence à l'avenir et considérer
ses forces de l'islam salafiste non
violent est aussi apprend en
considération dans l'équation à mon avis
bon les démocratie en Afrique dans tout
ça c'est là évidemment on touche du
doigt une apparente contradiction
interne comme on disait jadis au parti
c'est à dire que tout ce que l'on essaye
de décrypter ici ne signifie pas qu'il
n'y a pas au sein des Genèse africaine
une profonde aspiration à l'ouverture
sur le monde et à la démocratie
authentique le problème ça n'est pas une
sorte de désaveu démocratique c'est que
les versions de la démocratie formelle
qu'il aurait été proposé par des
pouvoirs civils successifs ont dévalué
l'idéal démocratique et y compris
d'ailleurs dans son expression
électorale quand vous avez l'impression
que votre voix ne compte pas ou qu'elle
sera anéantie par la fraude ou par la
corruption par l'achat des consciences
vous en venez à renoncer à cette idéale
là donc c'est là où il faut pas se
tromper de perspective non plus et
considérer que toutes ces sociétés
africaines seraient embarquées dans un
même élan d'adhésion à un projet de
nature totalitaire non ça n'est pas la
réalité sociale
pour conclure
oui je parle pas que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites et ont été de façon juste
je n'ai pas l'impression que l'islam est
né dans le Sahel ou qu'il est devenu un
sanctuaire de l'Islam ou en général
faire le prochain pèlerinage mais le
fait que aujourd'hui il y a un besoin à
la fois de bonne gouvernance et surtout
de gestion de répartition de la richesse
et pose un problème et qui n'est pas lié
qu'à la fonction idéologique et
religieuse or aujourd'hui tout cela en
forme et prend de l'importance parce que
il y a eu dans les années 90 la guerre
contre l'islamisme en Algérie qui a été
décalé vers le Sahel et qui a trouvé un
terrain d'expression à lassassinat de
Kadhafi du colonel Kadhafi ou les armes
ont été distribuées des armes ont été
également récupérés dans l'arsenal de
Kadhafi étant descendu
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en
directe de Lomé merci Niaga les vagayoko
merci voici l'astre notre spécialiste
des mouvements djihadistes merci Vincent
Vincent hugeot merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et restez avec nous sur
France 24
[Musique]